When you were a kid, making friends might have seemed easy and natural. You were surrounded by potential playmates at school and on the playground, and friendships just seemed to happen. And college may have been another situation where friendships easily blossomed. But for many adults, making new friends and maintaining old friendships is more difficult. We're all busy with work or partners, child care, and other grown-up responsibilities, and friendships often end up taking a backseat to the other priorities in our lives. Why is that? Why is it so hard to make friends as an adult?
当你还是个孩子的时候，交朋友似乎既容易又自然。在学校和操场上，你身边到处都是潜在的玩伴，友谊似乎自然而然就产生了。大学可能也是另一种友谊容易萌芽的环境。但对于许多成年人来说，结交新朋友和维持旧友谊变得更加困难。我们都忙于工作、伴侣、照顾孩子以及其他成年人的责任，友谊往往在生活中被排到了次要位置。这是为什么呢？为什么成年后交朋友这么难？
And why don't we prioritize friendship more? If you want to make new friends, what's the best way to do it? What about strengthening and rekindling old friendship ties? What are the essential ingredients of being a good friend? And how do you know which friendships are worth the effort to maintain? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
为什么我们不更重视友谊呢？如果你想结交新朋友，最好的方法是什么？如何加强和重燃旧友谊？成为好朋友的基本要素是什么？你如何知道哪些友谊值得花精力去维护？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
Our guest today is Dr. Marissa Franco, a psychologist and friendship expert who is working on a book about friendship called Plotonic due out later this year. Dr. Franco is a counseling psychologist and an assistant clinical professor at the University of Maryland. She was previously an assistant professor of psychology at Georgia State University. She writes a blog on friendship for psychology today and has also written for or given interviews about friendship to many news outlets, including Scientific American and the New York Times to name just a couple. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Franco. Happy to be here.
我们今天的嘉宾是玛丽莎·佛朗哥博士，她是一位心理学家和友谊专家，正在撰写一本关于友谊的书，书名是《柏拉图式》，将于今年晚些时候出版。佛朗哥博士是一位咨询心理学家，也是马里兰大学的临床助理教授。她曾任佐治亚州立大学心理学助理教授。她为《今日心理学》撰写关于友谊的博客，也曾为许多新闻媒体撰写过关于友谊的文章或接受过采访，包括《科学美国人》和《纽约时报》等等。感谢您今天加入我们，佛朗哥博士。很高兴来到这里。
Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a question I posed in the introduction. Why does it seem like it's so much harder to make friends as we get older? Is it that we're busy with adult responsibilities or is there more to it? I think that it's the context that we're in. So sociologists have argued that there's a few ingredients that need to be at play for friendship to happen organically. And that's continuous unplanned interaction and shared vulnerability.
非常感谢邀请我。让我们从我在介绍中提出的问题开始。为什么随着年龄的增长，交朋友似乎变得困难多了？是因为我们忙于成年人的责任，还是有其他原因？我认为这是我们所处的环境造成的。社会学家认为，友谊要自然发生，需要具备几个要素。那就是持续的、非计划性的互动和共同的脆弱性。
And we have that when we're younger. You know, like at school, we're on the playground. We have recess. We have all these clubs. But as we move on into adulthood, we're not in a lot of environments that allow for continuous unplanned interaction and shared vulnerability. I mean, like, work gives us continuous unplanned interaction, but often there's professionalism norms where people aren't actually sharing a lot about themselves. And so that really impedes connection. And so I think it's just
当我们年轻时，我们拥有这些。比如在学校，我们在操场上。我们有课间休息。我们有各种各样的社团。但当我们进入成年期，我们所处的环境大多不允许持续的、非计划性的互动和共同的脆弱性。我的意思是，工作确实提供了持续的、非计划性的互动，但通常存在职业规范，人们实际上并没有分享太多关于自己的事情。这确实阻碍了联系。所以我认为这只是
that we no longer find ourselves in the environments that have the right conditions for friendship, unless we intentionally seek them out as adults. Is there an age when this becomes particularly a parent or some stage of life when people realize that it's gotten harder to make friends? Yeah, I mean, I would argue that it tends to start after college where you no longer have those, that environment. But what we see in the research is that people actually have the most friends in their young to mid-20s and then it tends to taper out over time. Some of this is actually arguably good. There's a theory called the socio-emotional selectivity hypothesis, which which basically argues and finds that as we get older, we focus more on quality rather than quantity because
我们不再处于具备友谊合适条件的环境中，除非我们作为成年人刻意去寻找它们。有没有一个年龄段会特别明显，或者人生中某个阶段人们意识到交朋友变得更难了？是的，我认为这往往始于大学毕业后，那时你不再拥有那种环境。但我们在研究中看到，人们实际上在20岁出头到30岁出头时拥有的朋友最多，之后往往会随着时间的推移而减少。其中一些实际上可以说是好事。有一个理论叫做“社会情绪选择性理论”，它基本上认为并发现，随着年龄增长，我们更关注质量而不是数量，因为
we're thinking, you know, I have X amount of time left and when I spend it with people that really matter. Whereas when we're younger, we're focused on expanding our sense of identity. So we're just like, I'm going to be open all different types of people who are going to show me new and different things. So just what tends to happen is that we shrink our circles over time, but I'm not exactly sure if that's because it's getting harder or because we're also doing so intentionally. So in a recent article, you referenced a study that found that people on average have fewer friends than they used to. Friendship networks seem to have shrunk over the past several decades. Why do you think that's happening and is that a problem? Absolutely. I mean, the recent research has found,
我们在想，我剩下的时间不多了，我想把它花在真正重要的人身上。而当我们年轻时，我们专注于扩展我们的自我意识。所以我们就像是，我要对各种各样的人敞开心扉，他们会向我展示新的和不同的东西。所以往往发生的情况是，我们的圈子随着时间推移而缩小，但我不太确定这是因为交朋友变难了，还是因为我们也在刻意这样做。在最近的一篇文章中，你引用了一项研究，发现人们平均拥有的朋友比过去少了。过去几十年来，友谊网络似乎缩小了。你认为这是为什么？这是一个问题吗？绝对是。我的意思是，最近的研究发现，
and this was conducted in the pandemic. So that's a caveat that compared to like decades ago, people are four to five times more likely to have no friends. And it's worse among men compared to, I think it was like a few decades ago, like early 90s. The amount of men that have no friends has, has risen fivefold and fourfold for women. And so other meta analyses and meta analyses just combined research amongst a bunch of different studies have been finding that our friendship networks have been decreasing over time. And I think that this is a crisis. It's a public health crisis because, you know, loneliness is as toxic for our bodies as smoking 15 cigarettes a day, the science finds. For our longevity, actually, our social connection matters more than even our
这是在疫情期间进行的。所以这是一个需要注意的前提，与几十年前相比，人们没有朋友的可能性高出四到五倍。在男性中，这种情况比几十年前（比如90年代初）更严重。没有朋友的男性数量增加了五倍，女性增加了四倍。其他荟萃分析——荟萃分析只是结合了许多不同研究的结果——也发现我们的友谊网络随着时间的推移在减少。我认为这是一场危机。这是一场公共卫生危机，因为科学发现，孤独对我们身体的毒害程度相当于每天吸15支烟。实际上，对于我们的长寿而言，社会联系比我们的
diet and our exercise according to various meta-analyses. And so having friends, having connection for us as social creatures, it's just central to our health and also just central to our sense of identity, for us to feel like ourselves, for us to be able to explore who we are. Often we find pieces of ourselves and other people and we begin to incorporate that and that's how we feel enriched and that's how we feel full. And so I think as our friendship starts to decline, we're going to see more health issues alongside feelings of just like social unease or sort of like identity issues. So in your writing, you offer advice for people about how to make new friends and how to maintain friendship. So let's start with the first. What do you advise people who really want to
饮食和锻炼更重要，根据各种荟萃分析。因此，作为社会性动物，拥有朋友、拥有联系对我们的健康至关重要，对我们的自我意识也至关重要，让我们感到自己是自己，让我们能够探索我们是谁。我们经常在别人身上找到自己的碎片，并开始将其融入其中，这就是我们感到充实和完整的方式。所以我认为随着友谊开始减少，我们将看到更多的健康问题，以及社交不安或身份认同问题。在你的著作中，你为人们提供了关于如何结交新朋友和如何维持友谊的建议。那么让我们从第一个开始。你对那些非常想
make new friends, say someone who's just moved to a new city and is feeling lonely, doesn't know anybody? Yeah. So for people to make new friends, I recommend initially. We tend to rely on this myth that friendship happens organically so we don't put ourselves out there. But actually the science finds that people that see friendship as something that doesn't take effort are more lonely over time, whereas those that see friendship as taking effort are less lonely. And that's because they make the effort. I think the biggest problem is that we tend to be so self-defeating. We tend to fear rejection. We tend to think that, you know, if I reach out, they won't want to talk to me.
结交新朋友的人有什么建议？比如一个刚搬到新城市、感到孤独、谁也不认识的人？是的。对于想结交新朋友的人，我最初的建议是：我们倾向于依赖“友谊自然发生”的神话，所以我们不主动走出去。但实际上科学发现，那些认为友谊不需要努力的人随着时间的推移会更孤独，而那些认为友谊需要努力的人则不那么孤独。这是因为他们付出了努力。我认为最大的问题是我们往往太容易自我挫败。我们倾向于害怕被拒绝。我们倾向于认为，如果我主动联系，他们可能不想和我说话。
but in fact, that's a bias that we all have. It's not necessarily true according to the research. There's a study on a phenomenon called the liking gap wherein the researchers had people interact. And afterwards, each person was asked, hey, how much do you like the person that you interacted with? And the study actually found that people underestimated how like they were by the other person. And the more self-critical people were, the more pronounced this bias was to underestimate how much people like them. And so my advice to people who are thinking about initiating a little bit more is to get into the right mindset, which was going to require you to begin to assume that people like you. And then going out there and initiating with new people is going to look a lot easier. And just to make this super practical, what does this look like?
但事实上，这是我们所有人都有的一种偏见。根据研究，这并不一定是真的。有一项关于“喜好差距”现象的研究，研究人员让人们进行互动。事后，每个人都被问到：嘿，你有多喜欢和你互动的那个人？研究实际上发现，人们低估了对方对自己的喜欢程度。而且人们越自我批评，这种低估别人喜欢自己的偏见就越明显。所以我给那些考虑多主动一点的人的建议是，进入正确的心态，这需要你开始假设别人喜欢你。然后走出去与新朋友主动交流会看起来容易得多。为了让这变得非常实用，这看起来是什么样的？
Simply saying a line like, hey, I really enjoyed talking to you. I'd love to stay connected, exchanging contact information, following up from there. So we just have to put ourselves out there, really take the risk and repeat. the benefits. Yeah, take the risk, reap the benefits, and believe that there will be benefits. Maintain your optimism, because if you're self-defeated, it's going to become a self-fulfilling prophecy. So what about someone whose concern is more about maintaining and deepening friendships rather than making new ones? Maybe we're talking about a new parent who's working full-time and finding that old friendships are falling by the wayside. What are some tips for them?
简单地说一句，比如：嘿，我真的很喜欢和你聊天。我很想保持联系，交换联系方式，然后跟进。所以我们必须走出去，真正承担风险并重复。好处。是的，承担风险，获得回报，并相信会有回报。保持乐观，因为如果你自我挫败，它就会变成一种自我实现的预言。那么对于那些更关心维持和加深友谊而不是结交新朋友的人呢？也许我们谈论的是一个全职工作的年轻父母，发现旧友谊正在逐渐疏远。对他们有什么建议吗？
Yeah, so you want to create your own continuous unplanned interaction. So I would say, schedule a monthly meeting on your calendar for you and your friend to catch up and put it there so that it's there and you don't have to figure out when can we find the time. It's there automatically so that you can find that time to connect. Other things that I would suggest is taking that assuming people like you and applying it to old friendships you want to rekindle too, right? Because often we don't reach out to these old friends because we're sort of like, oh, maybe they're not interested.
是的，所以你想创造属于你自己的持续的、非计划性的互动。我会建议，在你的日历上为自己和朋友安排一个每月的见面时间来叙旧，把它写下来，这样它就在那里，你就不必去想我们什么时候能找到时间。它是自动存在的，这样你就可以找到时间去联系。我建议的其他事情是，把“假设别人喜欢你”应用到你想重燃的旧友谊中，对吧？因为我们经常不联系这些老朋友，因为我们觉得，哦，也许他们不感兴趣。
They've moved on. they have all these other things going on in their life, they're too busy. But instead, hey, they're probably like wanting to hear from me and they're probably wondering about me too. And that being the mindset that can allow you to actually reach out to some people that you want to connect to. The other thing that I would say is as we become more busy, one way to keep friends is to incorporate friends in a goal that you would like to set for yourself. So maybe that's like, I want to walk more and finding time to go on walk with friends or I want to eat healthy. finding time to cook with friends because that gives you something to anchor your friendship around. That gives you the excuse. That gives you the regularity of the interaction. That's really important
他们已经向前看了。他们生活中还有很多其他事情，他们太忙了。但相反，嘿，他们可能也想听到我的消息，他们可能也在想我。这种心态可以让你真正联系到一些你想与之建立联系的人。我要说的另一件事是，随着我们变得越来越忙，保持友谊的一种方法是将朋友纳入你为自己设定的目标中。比如，我想多走路，那就找时间和朋友一起散步；或者我想吃得健康，那就找时间和朋友一起做饭，因为这给了你一个锚定友谊的东西。这给了你借口。这给了你互动的规律性。这对于
for maintaining the connection. So to follow up on that, how do you know that a friendship is worth investing that kind of effort in? I mean, this is really the $64,000 question. What makes for a good friendship? Yeah. I mean, early signs of reciprocity are very promising. Like you reach out and they're also reaching out to you. What's really important for friends is people that are rooting for your success. When you share good news, are they happy for you? Are they excited for you? Research studies actually find that this predicts how satisfied we are in the relationship, even more so than whether someone shows up for us when we're sad. So that's really important. We want someone who is looking out for us, wants the best for us. The other thing is, I really love this concept. It's called identity
维持联系非常重要。那么后续问题是，你如何知道一段友谊是否值得投入这种精力？我的意思是，这真的是价值6.4万美元的问题。什么造就了好的友谊？是的。我的意思是，互惠的早期迹象是非常有希望的。比如你主动联系，他们也主动联系你。对朋友来说非常重要的是那些为你成功而加油的人。当你分享好消息时，他们为你感到高兴吗？他们为你感到兴奋吗？研究实际上发现，这比某人在我们悲伤时是否出现更能预测我们对这段关系的满意度。所以这非常重要。我们想要一个关心我们、希望我们好的人。另一件事是，我真的很喜欢这个概念。它被称为身份
affirmation. And that means we look for friends who support us in becoming the person that we want to be rather than imposing who they think we should be on us. Right. So someone who's high in identity affirmation, if I tell them, oh, I want to quit my job and take an intensive Spanish class in Mexico, right? They might think, oh my gosh, I would never do something like that. That's so risky. But they would understand that these are my values, right? That this is what I enjoy adventure. And so they would be able to say, I'm so happy for you. I want to support you because I understand that that aligns with your goals. And that's actually been found to predict whether best friendships maintain over time, do we provide that identity affirmation? The other thing that's just really important
肯定。这意味着我们寻找那些支持我们成为我们想成为的人的朋友，而不是把他们认为我们应该成为的样子强加给我们。对吧。所以一个具有高度身份肯定的人，如果我告诉他们，哦，我想辞职去墨西哥参加一个密集的西班牙语课程，对吧？他们可能会想，天哪，我永远不会做那样的事。那太冒险了。但他们会理解这是我的价值观，对吧？这是我享受的冒险。所以他们能够说，我真为你高兴。我想支持你，因为我理解这符合你的目标。这实际上被发现可以预测最好的友谊是否能长期维持，我们是否提供了那种身份肯定？另一件非常重要的事情
is perspective taking. Unhealthy relationships, toxic relationship. Often there's a breakdown in perspective taking. I'm thinking about my needs. I'm not thinking about your needs. So just for an example, an interview that I did in my book, this woman got sick during the pen, She wasn't sure what it was. She was supposed to go to a dance contest with her friend. She says, I can't. I have some serious illness. It's a pandemic. Her friend says, I can't believe you abandoned me. You're a horrible friend. That friend clearly is only thinking about her needs. I want my friend to show up to this dance competition, but not thinking about her friend's needs at all. And so healthy relationships, we want to find people who balance their own needs and
是换位思考。不健康的、有毒的关系。通常在换位思考上存在崩溃。我只考虑我的需求。我不考虑你的需求。举个例子，我在书中做过一次采访，这个女人在疫情期间生病了，她不确定是什么病。她本应和朋友去参加一个舞蹈比赛。她说，我不能去。我得了严重的病。这是疫情期间。她的朋友说，我不敢相信你抛弃了我。你是个糟糕的朋友。那个朋友显然只考虑她自己的需求。我希望我的朋友出现在这个舞蹈比赛中，但根本没有考虑她朋友的需求。所以健康的友谊，我们想要找到那些平衡自身需求和
our needs and try to collaborate and figure out how to navigate things in a way that is a win-win and suits both of us. You know, there's a lot of talk these days about ghosting people who just sort of drop out. You thought things were going well and all of a sudden they're not returning your calls and texts. How do you know when you've been ghosted and it's time to just give it up that this person is somehow giving you a signal but not a straightforward, I don't want to see you anymore? So it's really hard because honestly, friendship more than any other relationship tends to be a relationship of so much ambiguity. And that's because, you know, in our, in our marriage, we have this formal contract where we're connected and our family, it's blood. But friendship,
我们需求的人，并尝试合作，找出一种双赢的方式来处理事情，适合我们双方。你知道，这些天关于“幽灵化”（ghosting）——那些突然消失的人——有很多讨论。你以为事情进展顺利，突然间他们不再回复你的电话和短信了。你如何知道你被“幽灵化”了，是时候放弃了，这个人以某种方式给了你信号，但不是直接说“我不想再见你了”？这真的很难，因为老实说，友谊比任何其他关系都更容易成为一种充满歧义的关系。这是因为，你知道，在我们的婚姻中，我们有这种正式的契约，我们是相连的；在我们的家庭中，这是血缘。但友谊，
it's just you don't quite know what the expectations are and you're always just trying to figure it out. And so when it comes to ghosting, I like to maintain an air of optimism. If I haven't heard back from someone, I like to assume they're busy and, you know, give them that grace and not take it as personally. And I think that's a good starting assumption. I think when you take a step back and look at the larger landscape of the friendship, does this ghosting reflect a larger lack of investment or interest in the friendship, right? How are they showing up when we interact one-on-one? Are they willing to interact one-on-one? Are they willing to interact face-to-face? And do they seem interested, engaged? Do they affirm me when we're interacting one-on-one?
你不太清楚期望是什么，你总是试图弄清楚。所以当谈到“幽灵化”时，我喜欢保持一种乐观的态度。如果我没有收到某人的回复，我喜欢假设他们很忙，你知道，给他们那种宽容，不要太往心里去。我认为这是一个很好的初始假设。我认为当你退后一步，审视友谊的更大图景时，这种“幽灵化”是否反映了对友谊缺乏投入或兴趣？对吧？当我们一对一互动时，他们表现如何？他们愿意一对一互动吗？他们愿意面对面互动吗？他们看起来感兴趣、投入吗？当我们一对一互动时，他们肯定我吗？
All of that is information and the sort of not responding to your text message should be a data point within the larger realm of information, right? The fact that someone didn't respond to your text message alone does not indicate that they're trying to go send you or end the relationship. So I just think it takes us taking a step back and evaluating the landscape of the friendship more broadly to try to figure out what's going on. And I say, like, people are so afraid of conflict and friendship to the extent that they'd rather just end the friendship, right? but actually the science finds that when we have open empathic discussion of issues in our relationships, we tend to experience more intimacy. And so if you're just avoiding conflict, you might actually be harming your friendships,
所有这些都是信息，那种不回复你的短信应该是在更大信息领域内的一个数据点，对吧？仅仅因为某人没有回复你的短信并不意味着他们试图“幽灵化”你或结束这段关系。所以我只是认为这需要我们退后一步，更广泛地评估友谊的图景，以试图弄清楚发生了什么。我说，人们太害怕友谊中的冲突了，以至于他们宁愿结束友谊，对吧？但实际上科学发现，当我们对关系中的问题进行开放、共情的讨论时，我们往往会体验到更多的亲密感。所以如果你只是在回避冲突，你可能实际上是在伤害你的友谊，
actually, because I think a lot of people avoid it because they think, oh, it's better this way. You know, I'm not going to bring this up. I'm not going to cause all this tension. But the tension is already there. The question is whether you can work through it and have that opportunity or not. And so that's another thing. if someone's ghosting on you and you're not sure, I would just invite a conversation.
实际上，因为我认为很多人回避它是因为他们想，哦，这样更好。你知道，我不会提起这件事。我不会引起所有这些紧张。但紧张已经存在了。问题是你是否能解决它并获得那个机会。所以这是另一件事。如果有人在“幽灵化”你，而你不确定，我会建议发起一次对话。
Like, hey, I haven't heard back from you. Not sure if that's because something might be going on. But if so, I just wanted to welcome you to bring up any concerns that you have because I'm here to listen. So again, I mean, it's really about putting yourself out there and taking a little bit of a risk and hoping that you get a good answer. Absolutely. I mean, connection is this sort of schism of being the most risky thing we feel like we can
比如，嘿，我没收到你的回复。不确定是不是因为发生了什么事。但如果是这样，我只是想欢迎你提出你的任何顾虑，因为我在这里倾听。所以再说一次，这真的是关于走出去，承担一点风险，并希望你得到一个好的答案。绝对是。我的意思是，联系是这种我们觉得最冒险的事情，
engage in, but also the most nurturing and important. thing we can engage in. It's both petrifying and gorgeous at the same time. So I want to go back to something that you were talking about a little while ago, the differences between men and women and friendships, and especially what you were saying about men, which struck me as being very, very sad. I've seen articles in mainstream media that talk about how women are better at making friends and maintaining those friendships. Is there research that backs that up? Yeah. Well, there is science that finds that men just tend to be less vulnerable in their friendships. And vulnerability we find in the science, the more people disclose vulnerably about themselves, the more liked they are.
但同时也是最滋养和重要的事情。它既令人恐惧又美丽。所以我想回到你刚才谈到的一点，男性和女性在友谊上的差异，特别是你说的关于男性的部分，这让我觉得非常、非常悲伤。我看到主流媒体上的文章谈论女性如何更擅长交朋友和维持这些友谊。有研究支持这一点吗？是的。嗯，确实有科学发现，男性在友谊中往往不那么脆弱。而脆弱性，我们在科学中发现，人们越是脆弱地披露自己，他们就越受欢迎。
And people feel more connected to people that disclose vulnerably. And so while we may fear vulnerability for its potential liabilities, like, oh, someone can use this against me and exploit me, in fact, the more likely outcome, according to the science, is that it's going to cement the connection and bring us closer. And so I think a lot of the times men's friendship issues are actually vulnerability issues in disguise. There was this really interesting Atlantic article that talked about how men often need a third object in their friendships.
人们对那些脆弱地披露自己的人感到更亲近。所以虽然我们可能因为脆弱性的潜在负面影响而害怕它，比如，哦，有人会利用这一点来对付我并剥削我，但事实上，根据科学，更有可能的结果是它会巩固联系并让我们更亲近。所以我认为很多时候男性的友谊问题实际上是伪装的脆弱性问题。有一篇非常有趣的大西洋月刊文章谈到男性在友谊中通常需要一个“第三对象”。
They're watching the game together. You know, they're playing a sport together. And that is a way to avoid vulnerability by having a third object to focus on. But again, to the great detriment of the friendship. But I also have to point out there's this phenomenon called homo hysteria. which is men's fear of being perceived as gay. And so what that does to men is they feel like they can't do all of the behaviors necessary for connection because that might come off as gay.
他们一起看比赛。你知道，他们一起参加体育运动。这是一种通过拥有一个关注的第三对象来避免脆弱性的方式。但同样，这对友谊有很大的损害。但我还必须指出，有一种现象叫做“同性歇斯底里”，这是男性对被视为同性恋的恐惧。所以这对男性造成的影响是，他们觉得他们不能做所有必要的联系行为，因为那可能会被视为同性恋。
And so I've even heard men say, I can't even initiate with another guy. I can't say, hey, I'd love to hang out because he might think I'm interested in him, like sexually. And so because of this way that we conflate absolutely any sign of interest or affection with some sort of sexual interest, that leaves men in a real bind where they feel like, oh, I can't engage in this relationship at all because then it's going to be perceived as sexual, but then they're left really lonely. What about platonic friendships between men and women? Are those any easier for men to initiate, navigate? Plotonic friendships between men and women.
所以我甚至听到男性说，我甚至不能主动联系另一个男人。我不能说，嘿，我想一起出去玩，因为他可能会认为我对他感兴趣，比如性方面。所以因为我们将任何兴趣或感情的迹象与某种性兴趣混为一谈，这让男性陷入了真正的困境，他们觉得，哦，我根本不能参与这种关系，因为那样会被视为性方面的，但随后他们就变得非常孤独。那么男女之间的柏拉图式友谊呢？男性发起、处理这些友谊会更容易吗？男女之间的柏拉图式友谊。
Well, I mean, there is the difficulty of obviously sexual interests, depending on if both parties are heterosexual. There's some interesting science on this that actually women tend to feel closer to their woman friends than men friend, their male friends. But men actually either feel closer to their woman friends than their male friends or feel equally as close. So men actually aren't reporting feeling as close to their male friends compared to the women friends that they have because often men access more vulnerability through their friendships with women. And so I think that's a real, you know, we talk about men being put into the friend zone when I'm like, you know, according to the science, that should be an honor because men's friendships with women are some of the best friendships that
嗯，我的意思是，显然存在性兴趣的困难，取决于双方是否都是异性恋。关于这一点有一些有趣的科学研究，实际上女性往往觉得与女性朋友比与男性朋友更亲近。但男性实际上要么觉得与女性朋友比与男性朋友更亲近，要么觉得同样亲近。所以男性实际上并没有报告说与男性朋友比与他们拥有的女性朋友更亲近，因为男性通常通过与女性的友谊获得更多的脆弱性。所以我认为这是一个真正的，你知道，我们谈论男性被放入“朋友区”，而我说，你知道，根据科学，那应该是一种荣誉，因为男性与女性的友谊是他们拥有的最好的友谊之一，因为
they have because what tends to look different when men become friends with men versus woman is that they are able to access that vulnerability. That being said, when men are friends with friends with men, they access more ease and more of a sense of relaxation than they might access around women. Let's switch gears and talk a little bit about the past two years. At the beginning of the pandemic, there was a lot of talk about how to maintain friendships during social distancing. And we all got used to things like Zoom happy hours and online game nights. Looking back, do you think the pandemic will affect people's friendship ties in a long-term way? Do we even know yet? You know, the research here has actually been mixed in finding that, you know, the pandemic has promoted loneliness,
他们拥有的。当男性与男性成为朋友时，与男性与女性成为朋友时，往往看起来不同的是，他们能够获得那种脆弱性。话虽如此，当男性与男性成为朋友时，他们比在女性身边时能获得更多的轻松感和放松感。让我们换个话题，谈谈过去两年。在疫情开始时，有很多关于如何在社交距离期间维持友谊的讨论。我们都习惯了像Zoom欢乐时光和在线游戏之夜这样的事情。回顾过去，你认为疫情会长期影响人们的友谊纽带吗？我们甚至知道吗？你知道，这里的研究实际上是好坏参半的，发现，你知道，疫情促进了孤独，
but then we sort of haven't been lonely, have been less lonely. And I think part of that is we kind of had to reconcile with the fact that we need to initiate with friendships. We can't just passively engage in our friendships and rely on, you know, I'm just going to rely on us meeting up every month at the potluck that someone runs. We've learned, I think, a little more in this pandemic, that we actually have to initiate to keep our friendship. And that is such an important skill that I really hope that we can take into the future. And if we can really internalize that, then it can really make our friendships better in the long run. The thing that I am worried about is for those of us that have been chronically lonely, you know, we know from the
但后来我们又没有那么孤独了。我认为部分原因是，我们不得不接受这样一个事实：我们需要主动发起友谊。我们不能只是被动地参与我们的友谊，并依赖于，你知道，我只是要依赖我们每个月在某人举办的聚餐会上见面。我认为在这个疫情中，我们学到了更多，我们实际上必须主动发起才能保持我们的友谊。这是一个非常重要的技能，我真的希望我们能把它带到未来。如果我们能真正内化这一点，那么它真的可以让我们的友谊在长期内变得更好。我担心的是那些长期孤独的人，你知道，我们从
science that loneliness is not just a feeling, it's a way of seeing the world. Lonely people actually tend to dislike people. They interact with. They report liking their roommate less. They report liking humanity less. They report liking people they interact with less. They report assuming people are going to reject them when they aren't actually. And that's because, you know, when we were lonely historically, we were separated from our tribe. So we were in danger. And so our sort of danger signals are just going off when we're lonely in ways that make it hard to come out of loneliness because, you know, if you're thinking nobody wants to hear for me and I don't really want to hear from them, I'm devaluing the value of connection even while I wanted at the same time.
科学中知道，孤独不仅仅是一种感觉，它是一种看待世界的方式。孤独的人实际上倾向于不喜欢他们互动的人。他们报告说不太喜欢他们的室友。他们报告说不太喜欢人类。他们报告说不太喜欢他们互动的人。他们报告说假设别人会拒绝他们，而实际上并没有。这是因为，你知道，当我们历史上孤独时，我们与我们的部落分离了。所以我们处于危险之中。所以当我们孤独时，我们的危险信号就会以一种让我们难以走出孤独的方式响起，因为，你知道，如果你认为没有人想听到我的消息，而我也不太想听到他们的消息，我正在贬低联系的价值，即使我同时想要它。
I'm pulled in two different directions when I'm lonely. People report wanting to withdraw from people and wanting to connect at the same time. So it just makes it very hard to get out of loneliness when it's really, really entrenched. But I always believe that it's possible and I think we need to maintain our optimism. And I tell people that so that they can remind themselves when you're lonely. Oh, it's not that I actually don't like this friend. It's not that they're actually rejecting me. It might just be because I'm lonely and that's shaping how I'm interpreting events right now. So for a lot of us, work provides an opportunity for making friends as an adult. But now with remote and hybrid work, that's changed the dynamic for a lot of people. And it's
当我孤独时，我被拉向两个不同的方向。人们报告说同时想要远离人群和想要建立联系。所以当孤独真正根深蒂固时，很难摆脱它。但我始终相信这是可能的，我认为我们需要保持乐观。我告诉人们这一点，以便他们在孤独时可以提醒自己。哦，并不是我真的不喜欢这个朋友。并不是他们真的在拒绝我。可能只是因为我很孤独，这正在影响我现在解读事件的方式。所以对于我们许多人来说，工作提供了成年后结交朋友的机会。但现在有了远程和混合办公，这对许多人来说改变了动态。而且这
got to be especially tough for young adults, say, in their first or second job, as well as more seasoned employees who might be starting a new position remotely, let's say. So you recently wrote about ways to make work friends even while working remotely. What did you recommend? So I recommend setting up continuous unplanned interaction virtually. So when I stop seeing my work friends, I just set up a monthly meeting on our calendars for us to interact. It's some of the same strategies that we use in person that can apply in the workplace to, like simply affirming each other. We don't realize that according to the theory of inferred attraction, people tend to like people who like them. And So if we can show people that we like them, they're going to want to connect with us.
对年轻人，比如在第一或第二份工作中的人，以及可能正在远程开始新职位的更有经验的员工来说，一定特别艰难。所以你最近写了关于即使在远程工作时也能结交工作朋友的方法。你推荐了什么？所以我建议虚拟地建立持续的、非计划性的互动。所以当我不再见到我的工作朋友时，我只是在我们的日历上安排了一个每月的会议，让我们互动。我们在工作中应用的一些策略与我们面对面使用的策略相同，比如简单地肯定彼此。我们没有意识到，根据推断吸引力理论，人们倾向于喜欢喜欢他们的人。所以如果我们能向人们展示我们喜欢他们，他们就会想要与我们建立联系。
And so just saying, you know, I value you, I appreciate you, I miss you, these are all things that cement and maintain the connection. Similarly, we need to initiate even virtually to make those connections. What does that look like? You know, hey, I'm the new person at work. I've been wanting to meet new people, was wondering if you'd be open to connecting. Or, hey, you know, we haven't chat in a while. Do you mind if we put something on the schedule?
所以仅仅说，你知道，我重视你，我欣赏你，我想你，这些都是巩固和维持联系的事情。同样，我们需要即使在虚拟中也要主动发起，以建立这些联系。这看起来是什么样的？你知道，嘿，我是工作中的新人。我一直想结识新朋友，想知道你是否愿意建立联系。或者，嘿，你知道，我们有一段时间没聊天了。你介意我们在日程表上安排点什么吗？
I'd love to hear about you and check in about how you've been. the science of connecting at work is really interesting because studies actually find that the more we interact with people, the closer we tend to feel, but at work it's the opposite. And I think that that's actually because we don't often share vulnerably at work. And so there's this way that we only interact with a single dimension of each other all the time. So I just also encourage a little bit more vulnerability. Like, how are you doing, cracking jokes, things that you sometimes feel iffy about doing
我很想听听你的近况，了解一下你最近怎么样。在工作中建立联系的科学非常有趣，因为研究实际上发现，我们与人互动越多，我们往往感觉越亲近，但在工作中却恰恰相反。我认为这实际上是因为我们通常不在工作中脆弱地分享。所以我们总是只与彼此的单一维度互动。所以我只是也鼓励多一点脆弱性。比如，你怎么样，开开玩笑，有时你觉得做起来有点犹豫的事情
in a work environment. There's just, I know people are scared, things can be used against me, and that fear is real, but there's just so many things that you can disclose about yourself that are safe, like your wins or your accomplishments, or your hobbies, or your weekend plans, just feeling free to share a little bit more about yourself to create that connection. And the last thing that I wanted to say is there's this idea that I call the employee myth, which is the idea that when we go to work, we simply become employees and we no longer have fundamental human needs, like the need to belong, and it's simply untrue. Having connection network is related to your engagement,
在工作环境中。我知道人们很害怕，事情可能会被用来对付我，这种恐惧是真实的，但你可以披露关于自己的事情太多了，这些都是安全的，比如你的胜利或成就，或者你的爱好，或者你的周末计划，只是感觉可以自由地分享更多关于自己的事情来建立那种联系。我想说的最后一件事是，有一个我称之为“员工神话”的想法，即当我们去工作时，我们只是成为员工，我们不再有基本的人类需求，比如归属感，这根本是不真实的。在工作中拥有联系与你的参与度、
your productivity, your creativity, how much teams can succeed, how likely you are to stay in the job. In fact, not belonging is the third reason that people have reported quitting their job within the last year. And so your ability to create connections is going to have a powerful effect on whether you feel happy and satisfied and fulfilled in your work. So it really is worth it. You've also written about cross-racial friendship and cited research that found that the more contact people have with others outside of their racial group, the less prejudice they were. Can you talk about that and maybe offer some advice about building friendships across racial lines? So contact with people across groups is actually found to be one of the most powerful ways that we
你的生产力、你的创造力、团队成功的程度、你留在工作岗位上的可能性有关。事实上，没有归属感是人们在过去一年内报告辞职的第三大原因。所以你建立联系的能力将对你是否在工作中感到快乐、满足和充实产生强大的影响。所以这确实是值得的。你还写过关于跨种族友谊的文章，并引用了研究发现，人们与自己种族群体以外的人接触越多，他们的偏见就越少。你能谈谈这一点，并提供一些关于建立跨种族友谊的建议吗？所以与不同群体的人接触实际上被发现是打击偏见的最有力方式之一。
found to combat prejudice. But with the caveat that this has to be quality interaction. And there's a study that actually found that when people tend to attend work events, they tend to feel closer to people at work. But this isn't true when people are interacting with people across races. And that's because when people interacted across races, they weren't having as much quality conversation. They were engaged in the conversation more so to get ahead work-wise rather than to actually connect with each other. And so we need to have those more quality interactions where there's shared vulnerability and we're talking about things of substance. But what I really suggest when you're connecting across race is to maintain something called habitual open-mindedness,
但前提是这必须是高质量的互动。有一项研究实际上发现，当人们倾向于参加工作活动时，他们倾向于觉得与工作中的人更亲近。但这在人们跨种族互动时并不适用。这是因为当人们跨种族互动时，他们没有进行高质量的对话。他们参与对话更多是为了在工作上取得进展，而不是为了真正地相互联系。所以我们需要进行那些有共同脆弱性、谈论实质性内容的更高质量的互动。但我真正建议在跨种族建立联系时，保持一种叫做“习惯性开放心态”的东西，
which basically means put all your stereotypes and preconceptions aside, right? I think sometimes we try to over-identify with people across races to make them feel like, oh, we know them, but then they actually end up feeling really stereotyped. And so don't do that. You know, don't try to approach someone and say, yeah, I also celebrate this holiday that I assume that you might celebrate based on your identity. You know, just leave that aside and let them show themselves to you and reveal themselves to you as a person. Let them show you who they really are. One more current topic that I wanted to talk about. There's been a discussion in the past few years about how political polarization is straining family and friendship ties.
这基本上意味着把所有的刻板印象和先入之见放在一边，对吧？我认为有时我们试图过度认同跨种族的人，让他们觉得，哦，我们了解他们，但他们实际上最终感到被刻板印象化了。所以不要那样做。你知道，不要试图接近某人并说，是的，我也庆祝这个节日，我假设你可能会根据你的身份庆祝它。你知道，把那个放在一边，让他们向你展示自己，并作为一个人向你展示自己。让他们向你展示他们真正是谁。我还想谈谈另一个当前的话题。过去几年里，关于政治极化如何拉紧家庭和友谊纽带的讨论很多。
People might feel pressure to maintain a relationship with a family member they disagree with politically. Do you think it's possible to maintain close relationships with friends? we disagree with very, very vehemently. I do think it's possible. What I suggest to people when they're figuring out whether to maintain these relationships is to step back and consider the larger pros and cons of the relationship, right? And so what that means is there's going to be a different calculus when you're deciding whether to be friends with a new friend who maybe has very different values than you
人们可能会感到有压力要维持与政治观点不一致的家庭成员的关系。你认为有可能与我们非常、非常强烈地不同意的朋友保持亲密关系吗？我认为是有可能的。当人们在考虑是否维持这些关系时，我建议他们退后一步，考虑这段关系的更大利弊，对吧？所以这意味着当你决定是否与一个可能拥有与你非常不同的价值观的新朋友做朋友时，会有一个不同的计算方式，
that are expressed in their political beliefs versus a friend you've had forever, who's providing you with a lot of different benefits just because, you can reminisce and you have these shared experiences together, right? And so you just have to take a step back and think about this person may have different values than me in this way, but what are the things that I also get out of this friendship? And how do I weigh those two things together? Because all of our friendships should be more good than that. That being said, there are people who might be like, you know what, having different values, having different politics is too much of a con for me. That's something that I weigh heavily as a con. And I don't
这些价值观体现在他们的政治信仰中，而与你认识很久的朋友相比，后者为你提供了很多不同的好处，仅仅因为，你可以回忆往事，你们有这些共同的经历，对吧？所以你只需要退后一步，思考这个人可能在这一点上与我有不同的价值观，但我从这段友谊中还得到了什么？我如何权衡这两件事？因为我们所有的友谊都应该利大于弊。话虽如此，有些人可能会说，你知道吗，拥有不同的价值观、拥有不同的政治观点对我来说是一个太大的弊端。这是我作为弊端而沉重权衡的事情。我不
think there's an amount of pros that could counteract that. And I say, you know, we all need to develop our own system. We all need to go through our own self-reflective process to understand what our needs are and what our values are and what we are and what we are willing to compromise on and what we're not. That being said, you know, I know from theories of racial identity that people of color who tend to go through experiences of discrimination then tend to go through a hibernation period where they only want to interact with people from their group. And so what that research sort of suggests is there can be times when we feel like we need to hibernate for our own safety, but that also doesn't necessarily last forever. And so we need to also
认为有任何数量的利处可以抵消这一点。我说，你知道，我们都需要发展自己的系统。我们都需要经历自己的自我反思过程，以了解我们的需求是什么，我们的价值观是什么，我们是什么，我们愿意妥协什么，什么是不愿意的。话虽如此，你知道，我从种族认同理论中知道，经历过歧视的有色人种往往会经历一个“冬眠期”，他们只想与自己群体的人互动。所以这项研究暗示，有时当我们觉得为了自己的安全需要冬眠时，但这也不一定永远持续。所以我们也需要
expect that sometimes when we have these differences and things that feel so valuable to us and that feel like they're part of our identities like politics tend to be, that sometimes there'll be periods where we might need some space, but we might be able to re-engage in their relationship over time. So I think, too, when we're making friends across difference, we should expect that there's going to be a little bit more ebb and flow. So as you're working on the book and you're reading all the research into friendship, are you finding areas where either the research is surprising, that the results are surprising or that there are areas where you think, boy, we really need to know more about this. Yeah. I mean, the surprising thing I've learned since studying
预期，有时当我们有这些差异，以及那些对我们感觉如此有价值、感觉像是我们身份一部分的事情（比如政治往往是）时，有时会有我们需要一些空间的时期，但我们可能能够随着时间的推移重新参与到这段关系中。所以我认为，当我们跨越差异结交朋友时，我们也应该预期会有更多的起伏。所以当你正在写这本书并阅读所有关于友谊的研究时，你是否发现了一些领域，要么研究结果令人惊讶，要么你认为，天哪，我们真的需要更多地了解这一点。是的。我的意思是，自从研究以来，我学到的令人惊讶的事情是
friendship is that a relationship is a relationship, right? And what that means is what makes our romantic relationship succeed makes our friendship succeed. Affirmation of another person, working through conflict empathically, vulnerability, right? But the problem is I think we tend to compartmentalize a lot of these skills to our romantic relationships. People are so used to working through issues in their romantic relationships because if they weren't, their relationship would end. And yet they don't transfer those skills to their friendships, right?
友谊也是一种关系，对吧？这意味着让我们的浪漫关系成功的因素，同样也能让我们的友谊成功。比如对他人的肯定、以同理心解决冲突、展现脆弱，对吧？但问题在于，我认为我们往往会将这些技能局限在浪漫关系中。人们习惯于在浪漫关系中解决问题，因为如果不这样做，关系就会结束。然而，他们并没有将这些技能迁移到友谊中，对吧？
And so that's what I want to share. Think about transferable skills. What are skills you've developed from your marriage that you can bring into your friendship to make it better in that same way? And the other thing that I would say is that, you know how I talked about are the liking gap and our bias to assume people like us less than we do? That's true across the board with all different types of intimacy. There's this phenomenon called the Beautiful Mess Effect, which finds that when we are vulnerable, we think people are judging us more than they actually are. There's studies
所以这就是我想分享的。思考一下可迁移的技能。你在婚姻中培养了哪些技能，可以运用到友谊中，以同样的方式让友谊变得更好？另外我想说的是，你知道我谈到过“好感差距”以及我们倾向于认为别人不如我们喜欢他们那样喜欢我们的偏见吗？这在各种亲密关系中都是如此。有一种现象叫做“美丽的混乱效应”，研究发现，当我们展现脆弱时，我们认为别人在评判我们，而实际上他们并没有。有研究
on affection in friendship that finds that when we share affection, we assume that people will think it's more awkward and be less grateful than they actually are. And so when it comes to, to connecting, I should say, we really need to tune in to our self-defeating thoughts and recognize that we may have some biases involved and to maintain optimism, to assume that people like us, that they want to connect with us, that they're going to enjoy the interaction, that they're going to value the things that we do and value the things that we've invested into the friendship. Dr. Franco, I think you have given us some really good advice about how to be friends, get friends, maintain friends. Thank you so much. And I hope our listeners really get something out of this,
关于友谊中的情感表达发现，当我们表达情感时，我们总以为别人会觉得尴尬，并且不会像实际那样心存感激。所以，当谈到建立联系时，我想说，我们真的需要关注那些自我挫败的想法，认识到我们可能存在一些偏见，并保持乐观，假设别人喜欢我们，他们想与我们建立联系，他们会享受这种互动，他们会重视我们所做的事情，并重视我们在友谊中投入的一切。Franco博士，我认为您给了我们关于如何交友、获得朋友和维持友谊的非常好的建议。非常感谢您。我希望我们的听众能从中真正受益，
particularly during the pandemic where it's been such a strain. So keep those connections, gang. Absolutely. Thank you so much for having me. And if you want to stay connected with me, you can follow me on Twitter or Instagram at Dr. Marissa G. Franco.com. I also have a assessment for your friendship, strengths and weaknesses on my website, www.com.com. And I speak on friendship and belonging within and outside the workplace. Thank you so much for your time. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening to us on Apple and you like what you hear, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us
特别是在疫情期间，这种压力非常大。所以，大家要保持联系。当然。非常感谢邀请我。如果您想与我保持联系，可以在Twitter或Instagram上关注我，账号是Dr. Marissa G. Franco.com。我的网站www.com.com上还有一个关于您友谊优势和劣势的评估。我也会在职场内外就友谊和归属感进行演讲。非常感谢您的时间。您可以在我们的网站www.combeatingof Psychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、Spotify以及任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您在Apple上收听并喜欢我们的节目，请留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至
at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Winerman制作。我们的音频编辑是Chris Condayan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。